we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very
important question i received about the
recent string of right-wing terror
domestic terror take a listen to this i
just wanted to get your opinion about
whether you thought that donald trump
was committing acts of stochastic
terrorism by trying to incite violence
against individuals and all of that
resulting in the bombs being sent out to
various democratic figures and
democratic supporters and they just
wanted to see if you'd consider giving
your opinion about that thank you i hope
you have a wonderful weekend bye yes so
III do think so if you've not heard the
term stochastic terror this is the idea
that if you have access to forms of mass
communication like the bully pulpit of
the presidency of the united states or a
big media presence or whatever sort of
mass communication method that might be
you can incite random actors to carry
out violent or terrorist acts that are
statistically predictable but
individually unpredictable what does
that mean it means that when Donald
Trump says things like the Second
Amendment people maybe can find a
solution if Hillary Clinton gets elected
a statement like that those are
statements that when someone makes a
statement like that
we can't specifically predict who is
going to be motivated to commit an act
of real-world violence when they hear
that but if you're reaching a large
enough number of people you can
statistically predict that someone is
going to this was a term that was
applied when Glenn Beck inspired some
guy to go out and target violently the
tides foundation nobody was talking
about the tides foundation at the time
that Ben Glenn Beck was spouting
conspiracies about it but someone was
influenced by that and actually went out
and was ready to commit real-world
violence unfortunately if I recall the
story correctly although some of the
details escaped my memory now
that individual was stopped before they
did it you never could have predicted
that that particular person was going to
take action but statistically speaking
when millions of people are have a seed
planted about something violent that
they could do or that maybe Donald Trump
wants them to do then you are in a sense
influencing someone to do it if you
can't predict who and I think the answer
is yes I think there is no question
whatsoever that Donald Trump's rhetoric
has been stochastic terror and I know
people will say David you're saying
you're calling Trump a terrorist that's
crazy you're you're suffering from Trump
derangement syndrome it's a very
specific term stochastic terror look it
up and if you understand it I don't know
how you make a good-faith case against
Donald Trump being a stochastic
terrorist on the bonus show today more
new studio discussion we will talk about
the 2018 World Series where the Red Sox
won we will talk about a lawsuit against
Walmart filed by blind Maryland
residents all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show look forward to
speaking to you then